[Music]
so monar the legacy of Monsters has put
out two episodes and the third will be
aired next week on Wednesday a bit early
thanks to Thanksgiving and this will go
on through December till January well
for every Friday release and then we
will have gxg the new Empire this April
anyway in the second episode we saw a
striking new creature which is the same
one that was also showcased in the
trailers so here in this video we will
discuss its Origins history biology and
the myth surrounding it and also what
the Filipino Legends say what it is so
let's get to it so what is the actual
name of the Monarch black dragon clearly
it is not baffet or a minion of it oh
yeah we were wrong on that one so yeah
we're just human it is also not cot
since it is reptilian in nature and
chots is a bat neither is it one of the
other flying Titans from kotm or the
missing ones no this massive
unidentified terrestrial organism or
Muto has been given the name the Iron
Dragon which does stray far away from
the kotm style of naming Titans in
response to myths and legends but it
fits pretty neatly with other lesser
monsterverse creature nomenclature like
the skull crawler warbat hellhawk death
Jackal and now the Iron Dragon well it
does have a ring to it to be honest so
in the second episode of the series The
Tree Of Randa Koo and Lee Shaw had their
first ever meeting with each other in
1952 and at that time both Kiko and
Randa were in search for what was
causing a mysterious Airborne radiation
phenomena but from different
perspectives one from the physical art
of physics site and the other from the
crypto zoology site so they come upon
wreckage of the USS Lon which has been
dragged Inland in one of the the many
Filipino islands not so far away from
the sea after investigating the ship
which Randa had been on 9 years prior
and was the sole survivor of a Titan
encounter they were attacked by a large
dragon-like creature which looked more
like a Nar guga from the Monster Hunter
franchise than a proper Dragon this
creature is highly and fiercely
territorial displaying intense
aggression towards anything encroaching
upon its domain or its belongings which
is the USS loton wreckage here seems to
be 30 ft tall and 150 ft or 45 M long
which makes it somehow bigger than Dron
from season 8 of Game of Thrones but way
smaller than SM from The Hobbit and
Therefore several times bigger than toas
from the How to Train Your Dragon
franchise but also several times smaller
than the Red Death or the great bewilder
bees it is somehow the same size as the
bull dragon from the movie The Rain of
fire and that is our estimation we can
wait and get a proper official monster
profile for Monarch pretty soon or maybe
after the series ends so now let's
discuss its design its full design the
Iron Dragon is a colossal flying dragon
like creature It Sports black coloration
its scales are smooth and seems to have
small bumps all over the body and its
massive membranous wings look kind of
like bat wings but also drawing
inspiration from the flying fish with
its wings resembling Frills while the
Fearsome Jaws resemble the terrifying
anglerfish it bows a head that is adored
with two large Buffalo likee horns and
its jaws combine needle-like teeth with
a hooked beak like two nose hooks from
the front the monster has several spikes
on its back as well and it is equipped
with two legs that has deadly Talons and
a very long tail that concludes with a
fork design what is its real Origins and
the history behind it so in the context
of the USS lot's current location Bill
Randa enlightens Koo about the the
pursuit of a dragon drawing inspiration
from local folklores the Iron Dragon
featured in episode 2 of Monarch the
legacy of monsters is likely rooted in
the Filipino mythology specifically of
the babo trib's Tales From The Western
mindaa Island where they were in at that
time this monstrous creature shares
resemblance with the legendary minoa a
giant dragon-like bird in Philippine
folklore that is described as living in
outer space and can come and devour the
Sun and the Moon and would try to do the
same with the Earth alternatively it may
also find inspiration from the bakunawa
another formidable dragon in Filipino
myth however considering the proximity
to the bagabo tribes region and the
associated myths and causing these
radiation like afterglows in the sky I
would guess it is the minawa which seems
to share a lot in common with the
creature rather than the bakunawa which
is a sea serpent the Iron Dragon does
live up to its name showcasing
impressive flight capabilities with its
massive membranous wings that not only
Propel it through the sky but also
release radioactive ions creating a
mesmerizing Aurora like pattern in the
sky the creatures formidable claws also
possess the strength to effortlessly
tear through the USS lon's Hull which is
completely made of metal Additionally
the Iron Dragon exhibits a unique
ability to secrete a thick biomineral
secretion enveloping its prey and
preserving them perfectly for extended
periods of time executive producer Matt
shakman suggests that the reason behind
this intriguing Behavior could vary from
facilitating specific phases in its life
cycle especially feeding its young or
the newly hatched ones from its eggs
therefore making it very territorial
with respect to the USS Len ship which
might be the nest of its eggs or simply
it is just preserving the bodies for
later consumption which is highly
unlikely so this brings us to the last
question and that is what is the mystery
about it and the USS Len ship and did it
really drag the entire ship Inland well
Bill Randa was sure that what destroyed
the ship was a gigantic underwater
creature and him becoming the sole
survivor of that encounter therefore the
Iron Dragon being an aerial Muto
wouldn't be responsible for the ship
being sunk it is unclear as to how the
ship got dragged Inland but I'm pretty
sure it wasn't floating over High Tides
as the place interested in was not
really a coastal area therefore maybe
Godzilla or another large Titan got
entangled in the ship's chains or the
anchor and took it there for some reason
and then later the Iron Dragon claimed
it for its own when the bigger monster
left the scene this would also mean that
the dead Sailors were scavenged by the
Iron Dragon and it preserved the bodies
for some reason with a secretion that is
highly antibiotic given that very little
decomposition is seen on the bodies that
are 9 years old so the mystery endures
and hopefully more will be revealed to
us in future episodes and maybe there is
a bigger specimen of the Iron Dragon
which is maybe female or male that
draged the ship Inland for the female to
lay its eggs in well that's just a crazy
theory that we have so if you like this
video then watch this other one as well
and if you're more interested in other
movie monsters and creatures then check
out our Channel like subscribe and we'll
see you on the next video take care fam